This video is brought to you by Squarespace,
from websites and online stores to marketing tools and analytics.
Squarespace is the all in one platform to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business.
Check out Squarespace through the link in the description below more about them
in a bit
Paris, 1979, it's 3:10 PM. On the 2nd of November,
the day of the dead,
a 40 three-year-olds man climbs into a BMW parked outside his flat in port to
Keenan core on the passenger seat. His beautiful girlfriend,
Sylvia is smiling there.
I was leave Paris behind for relaxing holiday in Normandy.
That little dog scoundrel is excited to join them for the trip.
As the man wears his safety belt,
he positions two pieces of hand luggage by his feet carefully, though,
very carefully. They are 200 aides with the safety pins,
partly removed it's 3:14 PM somewhere else,
embarrass police radios crackle, and an order is relate.
The target has been identified and it's time to intervene.
The man in the BMW is jock Mr. Green robber, kidnapper, murderer, Syria,
Nevada, and public enemy. Number one,
he is wanted by the police forces are France, Canada, Spain, and Switzerland.
That man is also Jack mystery,
self appointed rebel one man army against the corruption of the Bosch wall
state, a modern day Robin hood, who only steals from the real thieves banks,
corporations,
and casinos and activist who has been campaigning against the harshness of high
security prisons, whatever the truth about Batman. One thing seems certain.
This will probably be the last minute of his life.
Sure.
A mystery was born on December the 28th of 1936, second child. Yeah.
And Monique who were small time entrepreneurs in the textile sector,
the early is of Jack or Jackie is his father called him happy and uneventful
until that spring of 1940, in which he,
his family and his country suffered the trauma of the German invasion PO was
captured and sent to a pow camp in Germany. Meanwhile, Mooney, you can,
the children had to evacuate the house and here suburban Paris and relocate to
the countryside.
Jackie spent the occupation years at a farm near PTA owned by relatives.
He soon found out that this farm,
it was a part of the resistance and Jackie was allowed to attend the partisans
secret meetings. At night by day, he played soldier with his friends.
It was in this environment that he developed a taste for guns after D-Day.
He witnessed resistance fighters, ambushing or retreating German column,
not far from the farm, the following day,
Jackie and two sister found a bloody mangled corpse by the road.
This was his first direct encounter with death,
which actually didn't shock him at all.
Some days later he would experience another first. The partisans had rounded up.
Some women accused of collaborating with the Germans,
or sometimes just accused of being sexually or romantically involved with them.
Their hat was Shaun or their faces beaten. Jackie stared at one of them,
a fighter had painted a swastika on her forehead.
This woman became the target of the partisans, wrath.
They with the butt of their rifles and they eventually killed tap in the
process. Her dress was ripped open.
Mr. Green later recalled this as his first experience with female nudity.
And it was definitely more traumatic than the corporate.
He had seen a few days earlier after the war was over. Jackie returned to Paris,
happy to be rejoined by his father. Soon, afterwards,
some sense of normalcy had returned,
but Jackie could not adapt to the daily routine of going to school.
After years of freedom at the farmhouse, he played truant.
Most of the time ignored homework and became the boss of a gang of street
urchins. By his teenage years,
Jackie had been expelled from two high schools on one occasion for punching the
headmaster by the age of 15 Jackie's dad had,
why isn't he decided to get him an apprenticeship?
Because studying was certainly not his strong suit.
Jackie worked for a couple of years at a fashion designers workshop,
even doing some errands for celebrities like Audrey happen. At the same time,
Jackie was staging his first burglaries with the friends.
His favorite technique was to end to middle-class flats disguised as flat
delivery boys. During this period, Jackie lost his virginity to an older woman,
a prostitute named Sarah and his memoirs.
He admitted that upon seeing her undressed,
he thought about the collaborationist woman who had been killed by the partisans
for two years. Jackie was smitten with Sarah,
even trying to get her out of prostitution, but eventually it at the age of 18,
he was too distracted.
First by his criminal career runs Zen by a young student from Martinique named
Lydia to Souza. The two had mounted a party at the city university or in Paris.
The sexual attraction had been strong intermediate. So in 1955 at the age of 19,
Jackie and Lydia got married.
The wedding had been accelerated by the fact that the DIA was pregnant,
but not with Jackie's child. Nonetheless,
the young Berger acknowledged the child as his own.
Probably not a great start for a relationship. In fact,
their marriage was not happy. One video had frequent affairs,
which also had the title of Saint slot. And Mr. Green's memoirs,
Jackie was unhappy. He took to the bottle and became physically abusive.
They jumped at the occasions and leave it all behind when the French army
conscripted him in 1956, the following year,
the couple divorced and Jackie volunteered to serve in Algeria training as a
paratrooper and command date. Finally, his love of adventure,
his passion for guns and his simmering desire for violence would all be
satisfied at the time.
The French military was waging a bitter dirty war against the Algerian national
liberation front, struggling for independence. Jackie, the boy was no more.
It was Jack the soldier.
Now he volunteered for the special anti gorilla actions and duties,
which included some pretty dangerous combat missions.
He also assisted the military police in torturing members of deliberation runs
or even worse, executing them with a bullet to the head in his memoirs.
He admitted to holding a blind to hatred towards Algeria and fighters there.
On one occasion,
he defied his sergeant's orders by releasing three Algerian prisoners.
One of the major only eight reminded him of his youngest self and Nazi occupied
France throughout the Algerian period. Jack lied to his parents,
telling them this.
He had been stationed in an away from combat when he was demobbed in April,
1959, his father was surprised to see a military CrossFit,
bravery pinned on his chest. Mr. Green was dead proud of his son,
but he also knew that the conflict was changing him.
He later admitted that Jack was never the same. After returning from Algeria,
something had cracked incite him and a new persona.
It emerged something that was dangerous.
Yes.
Around Jerry. Yeah.
Sounds returns. Civilian life board, Jack death. He craves adrenaline,
whatever the sauce. Initially,
misery and gravitated towards political violence and terrorism by day,
he worked as a textile salesman by night,
see frequency members of the OAS organization of the secret army.
This group violently opposed president goal's policy to grant independence to
Algeria. But Jack's preference was for ordinary crime.
He spends his nights committing small burglaries and playing poker in this
period. He partnered with an accomplice known as Gita, the Sicilian,
who would Manzur him towards more serious crimes. In 1959,
he was committed of his first serious burglary in the flat of a wealthy
businessman. As he was boring. His way into a safe is drilled breakdown.
Jack left broke into a hardware store, stolen, other drill,
and went back to finish the job during the same period.
He committed his first cold-blooded murder on a nice house with.
Jack had run into Sarah has old flame.
That was a violent altercation with Sarah,
his new boyfriend and pimp and Arab Madden and Ahmed Jacques enter the fight by
pistol with him the morning after argument beat up Sarah,
trying to extract Jack's address from Huck.
When Jack and Gita found out they kidnapped Ahmed and led him to the woods
outside Paris. They stripped him naked.
And then Jack slowly stabbed them to death with his Algerian souvenir of 15
centimeter dagga Jack, who was starting to build a reputation,
both in the underworld and among the police and the summer of 1960 after yet
another burglary Jack and two of his accomplices went to Spain to lay low there.
They were settled and tell us that Damar on the cost of Bravo one night,
Jack hooks up with a local girl, Maria Solidad. The two were an unlikely match.
Jack was brash venturous ladies, man,
Solidad was shy still under tight supervision from a parents and the Virgin.
Well, at least until she had met shock off to this on the holidays,
Jack and his friends returned to their old habits in Paris,
but this life was bound to be erupted erupted.
When an unexpected visitor knocked a Jack's door, it was solid Solidad.
She had gotten pregnant during their fat defining a patterns.
She had left home to move in with Jack and Paris, the two married.
So I'll November the fourth, 1961, and went on to have three children.
Sabrina borrows and Bruno fatherhood did not determine mastery in from crime in
January, 1962,
he was arrested on counts of burglary and carrying a concealed firearm receiving
an 18 month sentence. After serving as done,
Jack made a serious attempt to lead an honest life.
It first joins an interior design firm as an apprentice,
working hard and showing a real knack for architecture.
It was a busy then the firm made them redundance after less than a year.
Next solid dad's family had tried to help offering him that management position,
where they hotel in the North of France.
But the establishment soon became the meeting spot for local criminals.
And [inaudible] went back to his old habits around this period.
He made an important discovery.
It took very little to ultra his likeness pair of glasses, a hat or a wig,
a beard it's just a single detail could make an unrecognizable.
Mr. Green would exploit this talent for future criminal endeavors. Meanwhile,
Solidad patiently waited at home unaware that her husband had developed a
relationship with another woman, a prostitute, good GN,
Schneider known as Janno in times, you know, became more than a lover to misery.
And she was the second wife to him and an invaluable accomplice.
He introduced her to his old men taquito and even to his father,
both gave their blessing to that relationship. One night,
Juno was hanging out in Mr. Green's hotel.
When the bar was raided by a gang of thugs,
Mr. [inaudible] confronted the leader,
knocking him out with a truncheon without missing a beat unholstered,
a 38 handgun and kept the rest of the gang at Bay.
Apparently these were two criminal souls who were just meant for each other.
And let me tell you about something that was meant for you.
Today's sponsor Squarespace, two simple things.
Maybe you've got some idea for a website or a business or a podcast or something
like that, knocking around in your minds. And you're like, well,
should I do this? Well, two,
the only way to figure out whether it's worth doing is to get it out there to
the world. I know that can be daunting because it's scary to pursue new things,
but not knowing how to set up a website is not an excuse.
There are no excuses available with Squarespace.
Squarespace allows you to create a powerful website for whatever you're up to.
I want to sell something online. Yes. Set up a store with Squarespace.
You want to do a podcast short? Absolutely do it on Squarespace.
It all starts on Squarespace with a beautiful template that you can customize to
your heart's content.
Or you can start from scratch or you can easily move over from an existing
domain, making everything super easy to manage. Don't start from scratch.
They take my advice. Just use a template. They look awesome. Don't make excuses.
I want us you've gone through the super easy customization crisis,
no updates and a has no tech BS to deal with Squarespace, all sandals,
all the website stuff. Podcasts. Sure. Dailiness. Yes. Social integrations.
Oh yes. And much, much more. Also 24 seven customer support.
So head to squarespace.com for a free trial.
And when you're ready to launch go to squarespace.com forward slash fire
graphics to save 10% off your first purchase of a website or a domain.
The next appointment.
And Mr. Green's criminal resume is the most puzzling one.
On the 2nd of December, 1965, he was arrested in Palmer, dummy Yorker in Spain,
as he was trying to steal confidential documents from the office of the military
governor in his memoirs, Mr. [inaudible] claims that this was a job.
Somebody had commissioned ghetto to do the Sicilian as well as him,
but really who knows?
It's not clear the Lamar's newspaper speculates that this job may have been
linked to Mr. Green's old days with the OAS,
the antidote terrorists in the mid 1960s,
many former OAS members were hiding in Spain with protection from Francisco
Franco's military.
The Palmer heist may have even been ordered by the DRM French military
intelligence to retrieve a list of OAS, subversives and axle. Mr. Green,
the gangster has a government agents and interesting theory is supported by what
happened next. After his arrest, Mr.
Green was transferred to the French embassy and Madrid repatriated and given a
very lenient sentence in October of 1966,
Mr. Green gave it another go at honesty and opened a restaurant in the Canary
islands. Solidad was with him to recover that relationship.
The project failed miserably and the couple eventually divorced in 1967.
Shark and Jenner became the permanent item. Men,
both life ends in crime in November.
They first attracted the attention of the special squads of the French judiciary
police. The two,
a luxury hotel in Chamonix in the absence briefly held a Tennessean businessmen
at ransom after extorting a large sum.
The two lived on the run for three months with the police on their backs,
Mr. Green and Juno decided to leave the country for good. On February the sixth,
1968, they took off from Orly airport,
destination Quebec from February to June of 1968.
The couple were employed as Schaeffer and housekeeper by a Montreal millionaire,
George [inaudible], but after rounds with other staff, that was sad.
No job though. No problem,
Mr. [inaudible] kidnapped the millionaire asking for 800,
a hundred thousand dollars ransom after cashing in the loot.
The couple laid low for several months as guests of a widow who they preferred
it.
A couple tried to escape to the U S but were caught in Arkansas and extradited
to Canada around July the 16th, 1969,
Jack and Regina were both incarcerated. They were charged with kidnapping,
the Montreal millionaire, but also with murdering their friends.
The widow a body had been found on June the 30th strangled.
They were eventually acquitted of the murder,
but the outrage at this job prompted mystery into stage.
His first in a series of jail breaks on August the 17th,
the managed to capture a prison warden after stealing his uniform and keys
shocked them, proceeded to free his lover. Unfortunately for them,
they record the very next day.
And Mr. Green was sent to a high security prison St.
Vincent de Paul and Laval West of Ottawa.
Mr. Green now took his time to plan the next escape. Over the next three years,
he recruited a team of five accomplices and to create a secret stash of pools
from the prison workshop. Finally on August the 21st, 1972, Mr.
Green led his fellow inmates in a daring escape,
cutting through several fences with the tools he had stolen.
Once outside the permits at the six escapees,
simply flanks down some cars and hitched a ride to freedom.
Mr. Green had now partnered with one of the escaped convict.
So violent gangster called [inaudible] over the ensuing 10 days,
the two attacked three banks robbing them a total of four time.
On the 26th of August, they held up to small town banks,
10 minutes apart from each other on the 28th,
they raided a bank in Montreal as Mr. Green did not like that.
Funny look from one of the shares. They returned three days later for a second.
Ticed with the pockets full of cash and weapons.
Mr. Rena mercy eight went one step further. On the 3rd of September,
they attacked the old prison St.
Vincent to free some of that old friends still inside.
As they started the assault, they were caught between a rock and a hard place.
Wardens were shooting from the prison walls.
And two police cars arrived as reinforcements shock and Sean pool unleashed an
Inferno of gunfire green successfully hit the police scarves severely wounded.
The two officers inside mercy eight kept the prison staff at Bay until the
bullet caught him in the leg. Our numbers in almost down to the ammo,
the two jumps back in the car and sped off hounded by every police officer in
Quebec that DUI sought refuge in the woods for a week.
They were undisturbed until they killed two forest gods who had mistaken them
for poachers, you know, in the interim. Well, she was still in jail and Mr.
Green had made plans to spring hub, but when Jack informed her of his plan,
she Austin not to follow through on it.
Vaginosis specter that the police would lay a trap it up prison.
And she didn't want him to get caught.
Thus Jeno sacrificed lost Johns to see him stream.
And the two would never meet again. Mr. Rena,
I continued that robbing spree throughout October,
November and December of 1972, the two,
especially Shocket become national celebrities and counted,
or even if it came with a dark reputation for murder and violent heists along
the way, Mr. Green even picked up a groupie of sorts,
Joyce to rash this new lover followed him everywhere.
When he eventually decided to flee from Canada and return to France,
she followed him. He's in his lane.
So in 1973,
Mr. Green was back in France and up to his old tricks on March the fifth,
he wounded a police officer after a violent quarrel with a cashier at a bar,
a mistake that would cost him his freedom.
He was arrested on the eighth and scheduled to appear before a judge months
later on June the sixth at the courthouse in company Northwest of Paris,
as his charges were being read, Mr. And produced a gun stuffed in his belt,
he had retrieved it from the toilets were unaccomplished. So left it for him.
This was Mr. Green at his most brazen.
He held the judge at gunpoint and using him as a human shield.
He walked free of the tribunal.
That's the moment when Mr. And the gangster became a celebrity yeah.
Household name. It's also when authorities the plant in public enemy.
Number one,
as the ministry of the interior created a special squad headed by a comma San
role, chief inspector, Roberto Broussard,
Jack had found his nemesis Broussard and his colleague said a great opportunity
to catch a mystery. And September of 1973, on the 28th,
the gangster performed his signature mover,
double armed robbery of two adjacent banks.
Mr. And his gang made their getaway pockets loaded with cash bus.
It was close school. The police arrived in force and managed to arrest.
One of the gang's drivers.
The squad pressured the driver until they had an address.
The day off to Brasov squad surrounds him Mr.
Green's flats and forced him to surrender. Jack,
Mr. Green was again behind bars and they weren't keeping him at just any old
jail.
He was sentenced to spend a term of 20 years inside the high security wing of
Lasante prison.
This was a harsh institution placed in the heart of Paris and plagued by
overcrowding sexual violence and, um, sanitary conditions.
During the following five years at Lasante mystery and created a new public
persona for himself sharks. The gangster became Jack, the gentleman robber,
who only struck at the rich and powerful, but never Holmes.
That is a guy on the street. He became jock,
the activist who criticized the corruption of the government and the inhumane
conditions of the QHS.
These were the highest security wings in which convicts rotted in solitary
confinement.
As such Mr. Green became the darling of the media and the ultra laughed.
Mr. Green also took the time to write his autobiography instinct of death in the
bookkeeper reemphasized. How many of his actions while ideologically motivated?
Although he admitted that his pursuit of a life of crime was tied to his love of
risk and adrenaline. This is why he defined himself as a kamikaze of crime.
He also claims to have killed 39 people, which was probably an exaggeration,
but he did offer very precise details on some of these murders.
Instinct of death, of course,
was published prior to one of the most spectacular chapters of Mr. Green's life.
His escape from them,
Mr. Green's time in QA chess was not as harsh as he depicted.
He could count on the friendship of many convicts and even warden who had
smuggled cigars and other luxury goods in for him.
One of these wardens offered to help mystery and escape from the Sansei.
The man took several deep of the keys to the prison cells and smuggled them to
Mr. Green, along with two handguns tear gas,
canisters Pence's mountaineering rope, and a grappling hook.
Mr. Renin does accomplish dash the items inside the ventilation system of the
consultation rooms designed for lawyers to meet with their convict plants,
to protect them from humidity.
He wrapped each object with socks and rubber gloves.
And now we come to the time of the 8th of May, 1978,
Mr. Green is taken by gods into a consultation room to meet his liar.
As soon as they are alone, he orders her to stay silence.
And then he retrieves this tool from the aeration Vance guns in hands, mystery,
and quickly holds up some of the gods. One of them is the deputy chief warden,
Mr. Haynes strips him naked and wears his uniform.
Now the gangster locks them all up inside the consultation room,
then proceeds to free two more convicts, Francois Bessie, and common Reeves.
The trio lower themselves into a courtyard with the climbing rope.
They are expecting to see only at fellow inmates,
but they stumbled upon a group of guards and building contractors.
Mr. Green holds them at gunpoint and the tree moves on to clear the next
obstacle, the perimeter wall on the walkway. It's off the wall. Look,
God is keeping watch with a rifle, Mr. Ian,
incapacitates him with tear gas and then grabs his gun.
All the gods that are now in alerts and that firing against them mystery and
exchange has gunfire with the gods as best a lowers himself onto the street,
outside the prison, the bandit, then hands over the rifle to Reeves.
It's his time to climb down to freedom to is next,
but he loses his grip on the climbing rope and crashes into some scaffolding,
seven meters below, which is a bad fold, but he makes it out alive.
Now police reinforcements arrived as Reeves tries to stand up.
An officer shoots him, killing him instantly. Mr. Greene is ready to fire back,
but his gun jams, this ultimately AIDS his escape,
the police seeing his uniform confused and hesitate to shoot back seizing the
moment Mr. [inaudible] shoving the driver routes and they speed off.
This was the first ever successful escape from the Suntech. Mr.
Green was dangerously close though, to becoming a legend.
Any gangster would lay low and stay quiet for a while.
But Mr. Green was not any gangster on July the 27th,
1979 popular magazine Paris match published a sensational interview with Mr.
Green recorded some time after his escape in the interview,
Mr. Green acknowledged his respect for chief inspector Brie sought issuing the
warning that he would not be caught alive the next time. Surprisingly,
the gangster also admitted to further crimes giving very precise details.
For example, on may the 26th, 1978, Mr. Green,
as an accomplice had stolen 13 million francs from the casino Deauville in
Normandy, as he put it attacking a casino is to attack the empire of vice.
The only way to beat the house is to go with a gun.
Mr. Green and friends had barely made it out alive after being chased and short
answer by police on foot in car and from a helicopter after spending some days
in the woods of Normandy mystery and baffled the police once again and prepared
the next highest against a branch of banks, a C a T general,
this was an ultra random choice.
The general director of this bank had sued Mr. Green for slander following the
publication of his book, instinct of death.
When Mr. Green was forced to pay damages, he wrote to the director,
you are taking all my money. That's okay,
but consider this to be a loan on January the third, 1979.
Another interview emerged this time published by liberation here.
He gave details of his attempted kidnapping of Charlotte petty in November of
1978.
This is the judge who had sent him to the Sansei mystery rated the judges flats,
but its patina was not there in raged mystery sprayed the judge's family with
tear gas and left. The flat, the apartment block had been surrounded by police,
but the gangster escaped by taking another officer hostage, Mr.
Green's reputation with the press was not always.
So Corteal in September of 1979, ex policeman and journalist Shak,
Tilly accused mastering of being a dishonorable crook who betrayed as
accomplices.
Mr. Green was a little bit invited to the aid to a remote cave for an exclusive
interview. And the journalist fell into the trap. Mr.
N tortured him and shot him three times specifically.
He shot him in the face to stop him talking crappy,
shot him in the arm to stop him writing crap.
And he shot him in the leg just for the pleasure of it.
But fortunately he survived.
[Inaudible].
All the criminal activity, the interviews,
the confirmations and the successful escapes were an embarrassment for the
police and the government inspector Broussard alongside his new deputy Abella
Strozzi. We're often close to finding Mr. Green,
but they were always one step behind. Then at the end of October, 1979,
Broussard and Bella Strozzi received a tip off Mr. Green was living with his new
girlfriend's barmaids Sylvia and Shaq quo in the port to see you in a core area.
The detectives assembled a team of 50 offices in 15 vehicles and prepared a plan
of action. They would take Mr.
Green by surprise inside his car by blocking him at the fronts and rare with two
trucks.
Prisaad Galt authorization from his supervising magistrate to act in a state of
permanent self-defense this allowed maximum force reaction due to the danger
posed by Mr. Green. And now it's November the second, 1979,
the day of the debt at 3:15 PM. Mr. Green pulls out from his parking spot,
but a truck with a blue top hole in blocks.
The way then the top Olin flies open and three men armed with assault rifles,
jump out Mr. Green, immediately docks probably reaching for the hand grenades,
but the seatbelt blocks his movements instinctively all three men open fire
piercing. The windshield with 21 rounds.
Sylvia is severely injured and will lose an eye. Jack Mr. Green, public enemy.
Number one dies on the spot as predicted. He wouldn't be caught alive again.
The police operation and its aftermath remain controversial resolved,
and his men were seen drinking champagne by the corpse and hours later even
offered a glass to Mr. Green's daughter.
The controversy fueled the rhetoric of those who saw the stream as this sort of
folk hero, but should he really be remembered as such,
I'll only quote his spiritual testaments,
which he recorded for Sylvia to listen to after his death?
What is terrible is that some will try to make a hero out of me, but after all,
there are no heroes in crime. There are only men who are marginalized,
who do not accept laws because laws are made by the rich and the
powerful. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to subscribe also.
Please do check out our fantastic sponsors. Squarespace we'll link to below.
Thank you for watching.